(audience cheering)
- Welcome back everybody,
we are still here with Lisa
Whelchel and Rachel Bloom.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
And we're having an
'80s celebration y'all.
Well, I'm about celebrating
my upcoming 40th birthday.
I'm very excited.
I also wanted to use this week-long party
to shine a light on courses
that are close to my heart.
Anyone who knows me at all,
knows that I'm a huge animal lover.
I always say that animals can
often be better than humans
'cause it's a true statement.
Do you agree?
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah.
- My dogs are amazing.
There's a sanctuary just outside LA
that not only rescues animals in need,
they also invite humans
to come by and bond,
and they heal with the animals.
It's really, really cool.
From Kindred Spirits Care Farm,
let's say hi to Maria, Pierre the goat,
and Amaya the chicken.
(audience cheering)
(bright upbeat music)
Oh, my gosh.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Maria] With a little diaper.
- Wait, what is she?
Does she have a diaper on?
- She's wearing a diaper.
- Hello.
- Hi, hello.
- Hi.
- Oh, my gosh.
Are we allowed to pet?
We're allowed to like...
- Of course.
You wanna give him a carrot?
- Fine
- Can I put this here,
is that okay?
- Fine.
Can I give a carrot?
- Can I grab her?
Would you hold this for a second?
- Yes, got it.
(Maria laughing)
Here you go.
- Oh, okay, you're gonna babysit her.
- Are we gonna be friends?
Are we gonna be friends?
- [Maria] He's like, oh,
if you give me a carrot,
we'll be best friends.
- Oh my gosh.
How healing?
I just gave him one.
I didn't know how many you wanted to give.
Well, hello and welcome
to the show.
- Thank you.
- Meet Rachel, meet Lisa.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
Shall I gather my chicken
or you're okay with it?
- I feel are our names,
Rachel, Lisa, Kelly,
these are like all names
from '80s movies as well,
and Maria it's like amazing.
I just thought of that.
Well, tell us about your animals here.
So this is Pierre, right?
- This is Hanson Pierre,
and was rescued about two years ago
with his girlfriend Perla.
And then we have Amaya,
and she was recently rescued
off of a slaughter house truck,
and she came to us very sick.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And she had pneumonia,
and our director Karen
nursed her back to health.
We weren't sure if she was gonna make it,
but now she loves sitting on lap.
She's like a lap chicken,
and they're living their best lives
at the care farm.
Come here, Pierre.
(audience applauding)
- Pierre, you're so cute.
You're so cute.
I'm not trying to stop you.
- Doesn't he have amazing eyes?
- [Kelly] You want a carrot?
Oh my God, I just love how you eat it.
So tell us more about the farm.
- Well, our director, Karen,
started this care farm in 2013,
and she wanted a special place
that didn't just rescue animals,
but helped rescue people who had trauma
or needed healing in some way.
And so we have this beautiful space
with alpacas, emus...
(chicken clucks)
Oh, you wanna come down?
Okay, okay.
- She's like, this is my moment,
let me shine, ma'am, let me shine.
- Sorry.
Have your moment, Amaya.
- Yeah.
- Horses, a donkey, sheep,
goats, pigs, tortoises,
we have a great Pyrenees
named Hava, a dog.
Yes, this is all our sweet babies.
Pedro in the middle,
the top middle.
- [Kelly] Oh my Gosh,
are you just so happy all the time?
- [Maria] I know, it's pretty amazing
to go there and volunteer.
- [Kelly] It's so beautiful.
- [Maria] And we also
have a community garden,
so if you're not into animals
and you still wanna be outside
and let nature heal you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Maria] The Emus, they're hilarious.
And yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's beautiful.
- [Maria] And so we're working
on growing the garden and...
- Oh I got you boo, okay.
- If he's too much I can take him.
- Oh no, no, no.
You haven't met Henry, my dog.
(both laugh)
He's in my lap usually and he's huge.
- Aw.
- He thinks he's small.
- Oh, hi.
Hey, I'm hungry too, I get it.
(guests mumbling)
I'm like waiting for lunch.
- Amaya's over here.
- [Maria] Oh, okay.
- [Kelly] So she's just hanging out.
So visitors get to the farm,
and from the farm, they get
a unique experience, right?
So, what is that?
- Yeah.
There's like tons of
experiences one can have.
You can come and volunteer,
you can come and visit
just the regular public.
We're open on Sundays from 10 to 2,
but we also offer during
the week high school kids,
or elementary school kids to come
and learn about the animals,
learn about horticulture,
learn about composting.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
I would love to have learned
that when I was a kid.
I mean, I would now I'm like 39,
but like, yeah.
- [Maria] I know, me too.
It's amazing,
and we also then have programs
for adults to come that
need healing, like veterans,
people living in sober
living homes, they can come,
and usually adults wanna
get their hands dirty,
so maybe they wanna scoop poop,
We got tons of that.
- Yeah.
- They want to help build
a pen for the animals,
or fix it up or work in the gardens.
- Have a purpose that's selfless,
that's nice, yeah.
- Exactly, and just being outside...
- One more.
- Oh.
- Cherish the moment.
- Oh I'm so sorry.
(Maria laughing)
Oh, I don't care.
like literally, I love
animals more than humans.
So how do you see the farm
growing in the future?
- We have seven acres
and we'd love to expand.
We have beautiful rocks and
boulders on the property,
so we'd love to be able
to fence them and so...
- Love him.
- yeah,
so the goats can run and jump
because goats and rocks
is like bliss, right?
- Yeah.
- We wanna grow out our community garden,
and Karen, our director, her ultimate goal
is to have a walipini,
which is a semi subterranean greenhouse
and use it as a workshop place
and to teach about
horticulture and gardening,
and, so yeah.
- This is the coolest spot ever.
- [Maria] You have to come, yeah.
- Yes
- You should all come.
It's really close too,
about 25 minutes from here.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's amazing that you can go
to such a peaceful place
that's within the bounds of Los Angeles
and just relax and heal and
be amongst these cuties.
- In such a busy city, yeah.
'cause this is like, for me,
I grew up like out in the country,
so it's like, it's very different for me.
Like I feel like emotionally it's hard
in a city like that is packed
and you're not used to it,
it's such a healing thing to have.
- You need a reset every now and then
and just lower your vibration
and animals do that.
They're pretty amazing.
- [Kelly] You lower my vibration.
You're very cool.
You are so cool.
We are obsessed with everything
the Kindred Spirits Care Farm does,
so we are giving the
sanctuary $5,000 to help out.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God.
- Just buy all the Carrots.
- Thank you.
All the carrots.
- All the carrots for Pierre.